[Music]
hey you guys i'm back once again with
another
book review going a little bit more
recent this week
this one is from 2018 and it is called
the nightmare room by chris sorensen
this was another one that i saw
recommended a lot got a really lot of
good reviews on goodreads and uh
various things so i was really kind of
excited to read this one ordered it off
amazon it's been in the pile for a while
and i finally got around to reading it
and i will say this was a really good
book i mean this was one of those books
where i basically i sat down like one
evening to read it
and without even like realizing it or
straining myself or anything like that
i was like almost all the way through
the book like in one sitting
which doesn't usually happen because
usually other stuff interrupts and i
have it but i just got like so sucked
into the story
that i had read almost the entire book
without even really realizing it like
it's a very very easy read
so uh this is actually chris sorensen's
first novel
i guess he's better known as an
audiobook
narrator um he's narrated over 200
audiobooks and has won several awards uh
you know for doing that and he is also
um from my understanding a playwright
and a screenwriter and has had a lot of
his stuff produced
but this is actually his first novel
novel
now the cool thing about this is that
you know everybody says write about what
you know and stuff like that so
obviously that's what chris sorensen did
because the protagonist or one of the
protagonists of this story
is also an audiobook narrator but it's
not it's cool because
it has like enough of details like about
his job and things like that and some
things
you know when he's recording like weird
[ __ ] comes out on the recording so it
does kind of like play into
how the story goes but i thought that
was really cool but it didn't get really
bogged down
in technical issues or anything it was
just kind of like a background thing
that sort of enhanced
the stuff that was going on in the house
and i liked that as well
so basically this is a haunted house
story now if i didn't mention it before
this also um i think
the indie book awards i think this one
like best first novel of the year and
it's one like some other
it's been on like a lot of top 10 or top
you know lists for
2018 and like i said i can certainly see
why
it's a haunted house novel and you know
when i talk about the setup
it doesn't sound like all that original
but i just really really like what was
done with it and i just really really
liked the characterization
so basically the story is this there's a
guy named peter larson he who is an
audiobook narrator that's his job
and he has a wife named hannah now at
some point
before the events of the book have taken
place
they have lost their son michael to
cancer
so they're basically trying to make a
new start in life so they're moving from
the big city
back to this tiny little town it's like
a little college town
called maple city i believe it's in
illinois where peter grew up and where
his parents still live because it so
happens that i don't
i didn't get like a clear sense of how
long ago michael had died but i
think it was it was probably like a
significant portion of time because they
weren't still like in full-on grieving
mode they were just kind of
you know trying to get on with it trying
to you know put their lives back
together so i assume it had been like a
little while
so it so happened that peter's dad um
who's called big bear
is actually dying or he's not doing too
well and he had to get moved to
a long-term care facility because he's
showing signs of
dementia and whatnot so peter and hannah
pretty much pack up their entire lives
go back to this little college town
and they assume from what someone at the
real estate office or the lawyer or
whatever told them
that they would be allowed to move into
peter's parents house because they're
both in care now
you know and he just assumed and they
said yeah that's what that's what you do
so they get there with all their stuff
like after driving all this way
and then the other lawyer or whoever it
was like the
you know the more authority person comes
and be like oh no no um
this house actually has to be sold
to pay for the long-term care of your
dad and also his mom
myrna who was who was abusive and she
also has dementia
and doesn't remember him and um they're
both in the same care facility now
so basically they're like well we need
to sell the house to pay for
the you know to pay for the facility so
you can't stay here
and we've also had it the college that
is in the town has been expanding
and they want the property so they're
gonna buy the house
so basically peter and hannah were like
well [ __ ] now what are we gonna do
but then it comes to pass that
the person at the office that told them
that they could move into the house in
maple city was not entirely
wrong it was just that peter's dad big
bear
had actually bought like this kind of
run-down old farmhouse like out past
the you know limits of the town or
whatever and he had been renting it out
to you know workers and anybody that
needed to stay there
and peter didn't know about it so that
was actually the house that they were
referring to that was the house that
they were allowed to stay and they said
you can rent it for a dollar if you want
to buy it later on
you can do that so they had it kind of
all set up
in that regard they just got the wrong
house
so peter and hannah you know go to this
farmhouse which it's not like a complete
dump
but it needs a lot of work now peter is
just kind of like man you know [ __ ] my
life or whatever
but hannah his wife who's actually like
a kind of cool character she's kind of
like a
you know like a def leppard kind of
listening girl because she
reminded me like i kind of pictured her
in my head like
maybe i kind of pictured the the family
like the family from the devil's candy
that movie if you've seen that one so
like kind of heavy metal gothic kind of
people
or maybe like mandy like the character
of mandy from the movie mandy with
nicholas cage that's kind of who she
reminded me of that's like the vibe she
gave off
so she like sees this house and she's
very very excited she's just kind of
like oh man we can fix this all up we
can do this that the other thing
and he's like well you know she's trying
to get past the grief of like losing
their son and everything so he's like
okay well we'll
stay here even though it's not ideal so
it turns out though
that when he goes down into the creepy
creepy basement
he's like hey um it's almost kind of
like naturally soundproof down here so
this is where i'm gonna put my audio
booth where i can record my audiobook so
i can work down here
and that's actually what ends up
happening
however as in most haunted house stories
[ __ ] don't go too well like [ __ ] starts
going awry he starts hearing like weird
stuff on some of his recordings like
weird audio glitches
and as the story goes on like the
haunting or whatever it is
seems to be ramping up now the
interesting thing about this too
and when the book starts like almost
like a prologue
they're actually talking about a little
boy who was trying to escape
from his abusive dad and
he goes down like i guess he gets scared
and he
like wets the bed and his dad is like a
giant gaping
anus and drags the poor little kid down
to the basement and locks him down in
there and there's like a room down in
the basement
which the little kid you know kind of
thinks of as the nightmare room because
every time he has a nightmare and starts
screaming and wakes his dad up
you know he gets dragged into the
basement and like thrown in there
you know even in the very beginning of
the book there's some [ __ ] about like
the little kid and there's like
some kind of entity that's down there
that talks to him
um he's known as whisper or he's known
as mr tell
and um you're not really sure like if
the
if the entity i mean you know it's
probably real because you know it's a
haunted house horror novel and it'd be
kind of lame if it wasn't
but you don't really know like the
parameters of what this
entity is or what it wants or anything
like that so
interestingly this story like with
the little boy and the thing in the
basement and the nightmare room that's
in the basement that the little boy
stays in where he tries to like keep
himself safe
from this entity that's down there that
starts to tie
in with the modern day story now i'm not
going to spoil how it does i mean i
think i said on my
woman in black review that i'm not going
to be quite as worried about
spoiling things just so i can
talk about things a little bit more
freely that said though
you know i spoiled a lot of stuff on the
woman in black review but that's because
that book came out in 1983 and there's
been like a whole bunch of
movie adaptations about it so i kind of
figured that everybody
sort of knew like at least the bones of
the story so i didn't really feel that
bad about spoiling it this
book is still pretty recent it's only
about two years old
so i'm not gonna spoil like exactly what
the entity is or exactly how the entity
is tied to the modern day tied to peter
because there is like a connection there
but i will say that
it does definitely have something to do
with
the past with the guy like with um
something that happened at the house
that he forgot about
um something to do with memory uh
you know memories that were taken away
from him i guess
and also something that he did in the
more present day
that he forgot about but
not it wasn't his choice to forget about
it let's put it that way
so it's interesting because this isn't
as i said it's a haunted house story but
it's not a traditional haunted house
story because this thing that's in this
house
is not really a ghost it's like it's not
really a demon or anything like that
it's just this weird
kind of shadowy entity that has like
particular powers
and i'm not even sure i mean i guess
it's like a bad guy but i guess it's
kind of like
ambiguous because it seemed to do good
[ __ ] and there was something to do with
like the mom
and there was all kind of stuff going on
in there so it's kind of like a really
intricate like fascinating entity
that's been created in this book uh
another thing too
is that this apparently this is the
first of um
a series a purported series i don't know
how many it's gonna be
so this is the first book the series is
called the messy man series
um and i'm assuming i think the messy
man is what the entity is called now the
second book called the hungry ones
is already out um i haven't read it yet
but as much as i like this one i'm sure
i probably will get around to it
so i don't know if it's going to
be um concerned with peter and hannah
um you know if it's going to be
concerned with that family or if
you know the entity is going to move on
to someone else or it's going to be like
in the same farmhouse i'm not really
sure like how it's gonna go
but i'll definitely like read the second
one in the series you know eventually
when i get through my
pile i'll review that one too and we'll
see like what we had going on with this
one but yeah it's like
this is as i said i mean for somebody
that i mean i know he's not
you know he he wrote plays he's written
screenplays and stuff like that so it's
not like he's a complete novice writer
or anything and also he
you know narrates audiobooks so this is
someone that
for their first novel you know this is a
really easy read
it's like it's very easy to get just
sucked into the story almost immediately
i almost felt like i kind of like phased
out because i was so involved in the
story and then i was like holy [ __ ]
there's only
like 30 pages left like and it's not you
know it's not a long book but it's not
like super short either i think it's
like something like it's 250
200 something like that how many pages
is this let's check
let's check this is it's 263 pages
so yeah and i and i read it like in a
couple of hours like in one sitting
without even
meaning to so that should say something
about how
kind of compelling and how you know
intriguing the story is because i just
kept wanting to read it and see what was
happening um because it's just like this
mystery you're not sure what the entity
is
and another thing too is that even
though
i've seen most of the reviews i've seen
of this have been like very very
positive
um which i would agree with the negative
reviews that i saw
basically one of the main criticisms was
oh well it takes too long in the build
up you know all the character work it
was you know it took too long to get to
the scary stuff
but i'm not really sure i agree with
that i mean it's kind of hard for me to
say because
i read it very quickly so to me it
seemed like oh here's all the spooky
[ __ ] like already because i was just
sitting there reading it it took like a
couple of hours
so to me it didn't really seem like the
build up was
all that slow i mean right out the gate
you have this prologue about this little
boy
and his horrible abusive dad and some
kind of entity
and you're not really sure what's going
on there so already you have that
and then yes you have like a character
build up with this family and you kind
of
get a sense of peter and hannah's
relationship which is actually like a
really good
i really like the interplay between the
two of them they're very um relatable
characters that was kind of like
working class kind of um you know just
working stiff kind of characters like
hannah she tries
when they move to the town she tries to
go get like an administrative assistant
job like at
the college but she can't get it so she
ends up being a bartender which she did
back when she was younger
um and there's like a couple funny
scenes with that and also like the
the bartender that hires her or the or
the bar manager that hires her rather
is like also an old high school friend
of peters so like the interaction
between the three of them is just like
really
funny and it's like you know very
naturalistic so you can really kind of
get into these characters worlds
you know none of them are annoying none
of them do stupid things none of them
you know they're just like regular ass
people
and they're put into this situation and
there's also some cool [ __ ] too where
peter is kind of like the only one that
really
experiences any of this stuff to any
great degree at first
and so he's kind of in a position where
he doesn't want to
put more burden on his wife um
you know because she's still going
through the trauma of like losing the
sun and everything
but at the same time you know the crazy
[ __ ] that's happening is kind of making
it look like he's losing his marbles so
there's
like kind of a lot of stress but i do
like that it didn't really
put a damper on their relationship so
much as you know
as it kind of brings them stronger
together which i think is like kind of
cool you don't see that a lot usually
it's kind of like you know breaks people
up and they're like you're crazy no
you're crazy and all this other kind of
[ __ ]
so i like that even though there was a
little bit of that they still like kind
of had each other's backs even though
from hannah's perspective it looked like
peter was like losing his
[ __ ] but yeah that said i mean there was
a lot of hype about this book
and um i do feel like in a large to a
large extent that is justified
as i said it's not reinventing the wheel
or anything like that
it's a haunted house story with kind of
a twist
um you know like i said it's not a ghost
or anything like that but it has like a
lot of the haunted house tropes to it
so you know if you don't like haunted
house books i don't know if
it would turn you on to them or you know
if you'd be into it because it's not
that different but the writing of it is
really cool really compelling it's very
very easy to get into it's very very
easy to read
you know it's a very fast read the
character work is very good the
characters are all very
fun and relatable um the situation is
just original enough
that you know it has kind of like a new
spin on it and also
now that you know that there's a second
book
the ending of it is a lot more
compelling because you're like where
where's this gonna go because now that
you've introduced this
entity i'm kind of curious to see where
it's gonna end up going in the future
so yeah i mean if you're into haunted
house books which i am it's probably my
favorite
sub-genre of horror is haunted house and
alexander there's a lot of them
and a lot of them are very samey like i
get that but
i don't know there's just something
about haunted house novels that i really
really like
and um this is definitely a really
really good one one of the best ones
i've read recently so i would definitely
recommend it if you're into
that kind of thing so as i said it is
the nightmare room by chris sorensen so
that'll do it for
this tomes of terror and i'll see in the
next one bye